notre invité ce soir c'est le mec de
brefs
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir alors votre vrai nom seth
killian qu'aujourd'hui mais on va garder
le maître de brefs
vous savez comment vous appelez très
longtemps le mec de bref ce qui est
assez paradoxal finalement c'est vrai
alors début 2011 vous êtes dans une
période de grosse remise en question de
galère vous payer votre loyer à coups de
stand-up et de rsa vous avez envie de
baisser les bras qui a dévoyé pas très
bien ce qu'on pouvait faire de toute
façon exactement ouais je suis comédien
je sais faire que ça dans ma vie est
hors de question sur la chose et c'est
là qu'en préparant votre nouveau
spectacle j'avais l'idée de raconter des
tranches de vie d'un loser en gros oued
un mec normal sur moi raconte est super
rapide ouais ça rend ça rend la loose un
peu un peu moins évidente voilà alors
vous dites à l'image de la série tout
s'est fait très rapidement
début avril notre producteur présente
l'idée à canal bon qu et ont filmé les
quarante épisodes en août c'est
rarissime ouais ouais on a tout fait en
un jour on a fait rentrer 30 jours de
travail en vain
ah si vous fait alors le pitch est
simple au début on est à la fin on meurt
entre les deux il se passe des trucs
bref c'est l'histoire d'un mec entre les
deux
alors vous êtes ici ce soir pour la
sortie du double dvd l'intégrale de la
série bref du dvd blu ray intégrale du
livre et du coffret collector avec le
double dvd des bonus et une clé usb avec
la bande originale de la série
bref vous venez pas les mains vides
break bien bossé là dessus alors on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
c'est
bref un jour j'ai eu 30 ans tout le
monde m'a répété
je crois qu'ils n'ont pas tort à ce que
j'ai un pote qui a eu un enfant vote qui
est devenue médecin un pote qui est
parti du jour au lendemain dans un pays
étranger j'ai eu quatre pannes sexuelles
a exactement je me suis demandé ce que
je voulais faire de ma vie je dis non je
me vois pas me coucher tard à des potes
je rentrais chez moi j'ai pris un bain
et en plus j'ai mis davoust j'ai dit à
quelqu'un il sait maintenant que tu
verras plus tard quand je vais aux
toilettes j'attends un deux trois quatre
secondes avant de pouvoir fils et mes
potes me parle de crédit d'impôt ou de
retraite quand je joue avec mes
transformés en centres de vente il fut
un collectionneur one more time des daft
punk à 11 ans jurassic park ave 19 ans
les simpson ont 23 en hiver je prends
des vitamines j'ai déjà marcher près de
la mer avec un pull autour du cou kg et
messages edi best sont à quelqu'un qui
écoutait de la musique crédit et
souffler dans une rue qui monte j'ai
entendu des jeunes parler entre eux
j'ai rien compris je me suis rendu
compte que je les appelle des jeunes un
dimanche j'ai brunch et j'ai pris un
taxi parce que j'avais la flemme de
prendre métro j'ai trouvé qu'un jeu
vidéo allait trop vite j'ai acheté une
théière j'ai une marque de thé préfet ne
suis pas assez jeune pour la carte 12-25
et pas assez vu pour la carte senior
j'ai acheté des boîtes oranges et je
mélange plus les couleurs quand je fais
une machine mais je comprends les
tickets de mes pulls je suis déjà parti
en vacances pour me reposer et j'ai
utilisé le mot art n'a plus bougé restée
allumée j'hésitais à la souffler qu iron
l'attend
bref j'ai eu 30 ans
découverte autour du vin votre forfait
pour le nos logis depuis le temps je dis
qu'il faut qu'on le fasse un vrai chéri
allez je fais la bise à tout le monde
soit
[Applaudissements]
dans le wb les airs à 82 82 82 vraiment
vous ouais mais c'est un boulot de chien
parce que certains numéros il ya 140
plan quoi laisser sa vraie 140 coupe de
plan mais bien on a fait un record
c'était trois heures sur deux secondes
ah oui alors voilà donc en une saison
vous êtes devenu culte ça fait quoi
d'être culte au quotidien il paraît que
les gens arrivent à écrire votre nom de
famille sans faire de fautes
d'orthographe il gagne au scrabble avec
meghraoui eric laurent wauquiez aussi ça
fait le combat de scrabble aujourd'hui
alors vous devez une rock-star vous
faites le grand axe
rassurez moi c'est pas de vous dont
parle christophe hondelatte quand il
chante j'aime le cuir et latex et les
toilettes du grand rex au bas mot il
chaud en date
[Rires]
alors bref a inspiré de nombreuses
parodies en plus chez nous un style bref
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
ce mec mal réveillé la dans son lit
c'est moi dans la vie avant ma vie elle
était normal et puis les cette série sur
canal
un matin j'ai reçu une vidéo sur
facebook c'était un épisode de bref avec
écrit matin mais qui a t'on sosie je
vais sur le site et la direccte
j'hallucine ce mec c'est vraiment mon
sosie
[Musique]
bref aujourd'hui je travaille dur le
téléphone sonne je fais semblant de ne
pas entendre il continue de sonner je
tourne la tête ils sont encore j'exprime
mon mécontentement
dans la rue on a croisé mélissa theuriau
parce que c'est ma voisine
[Musique]
bonne journée j'ai regardé partir j'ai
compris que c'était pas mal in que je
devais trouver mais la sienne j'avais
pas kleenex gipa kleenex
j'avais pataca kaka kaka j'ai pensé
l'expression vie mais
combien de balles seront chargés par
être at-elle le cap et les casquettes en
plastique les pourquoi pourquoi
trouveront ils la portent l'acte est
d'accord la poignée de porte se
lancera-t-il dans la bd l'alcool la
coiffure arrêtera-t-il de la regarder
une fois trois fois dix fois ça va
[Musique]
c'est un des gars comme ça aussi
rapidement bravo merci vous vraiment
bravo et merci bien même il ya même un
préservatif bref way olivier geay
accusateurs preco
voilà et puis alors à la fin de la
première saison vous arrêter
ceci étant une cei qui s'appelle bref et
qui dure dix ans c'était pas très
cohérent finalement way et
personnellement je kiffais prison break
la saison 1 ouais et la saison 2
philippe en effet un présage
alors on passe maintenant à l'interview
portrait
[Musique]
alors qu'anne qu'aujourd'hui dans la vie
au début on naît vous c'est et le 29
août 1982 à reims vous êtes d'origine
iranienne comme la prochaine guerre
mondiale
alors en iran notre père était géologue
il est parti à l'arrivée de l'ayatollah
khomeini il s'est reconverti en france
dans le commerce de tapis c'était dur
pour lui de changer comme ça de la
situation bah c'est pas facile en plus
c'est cécile reste est vachement dans la
famille le fait de se dire les gars ben
ouais faut repartir à zéro plusieurs
dans sa vie même à 50 en tout cas le
pari mais en même temps il est marrant
votre père venu c'est un gros rat
conteur de blague ouais vous l'aimez
beaucoup un ouais normalement oui alors
votre maire et picardes
fille d'une femme de ménage très
mélomane elle aurait voulu être
chanteuse ou comédienne mais voilà elle
est devenue juriste dans un cabinet de
formation alors j'ai déjà les en iran un
oui une fois et je me dis mais tu es fou
s'il m'était complètement cinglé je dis
ouais je sais mais je faut que j'y aille
mais non c'était c'était normal en fait
c'est juste que bombe à la balle la vie
est un peu bloquée dans les années 80
donc le parc automobile est un peu vieux
mais j'ai jamais vu des gens aussi
libres dans leur tête c'est très évolués
contrairement à l'image qu'on n'en
exactement énième fois qui a une
vraiment belle image mais j'étais allé
une fois mais en revanche quand vous
étiez chez vos parents la famille d'iran
vous visiter souvent alors vous dites
tout le monde mangeait par terre et
rester dormir là y'avait toujours 15
personnes à la maison et des matelas par
tout ça c'est vrai ça j'ai grandi avec
des matelas sur les murs et quand la
famille arrivée up
donc bah ouais ma grand mère venait six
6 mois par an dormir à la maison et fait
près de repartir en iran j'ai grandi et
que cette double culture en permanence
et la culture américaine en plus dans la
télé donc ça fait strié rock and roll
votre grand mère ouais elle avait
divorcé en iran dans les années 50 ce
qui est rare ici c'est une femme que
j'aime énormément vous parlez persans vo
bruit dix mois un truc qu'on peut
ressentir et je suis très content d'être
avec vous thierry martin hirsch madame
tout salut
[Applaudissements]
alors le reste de votre vie est beaucoup
moins exotique vous passez les 23
premières années de votre vie à vous
ennuyer dans un quartier pavillonnaire
rémois mais un ennui formateur vous êtes
dit si je veux pas crever là il faut que
je me bouge je sais pas ça c'est que
j'avais un parcours classique lycée bac
études de droit ont maîtrisé je sais pas
j'ai un peu mal au dos en fait à chaque
fois tous les matins j'ai un peu mal au
dos et puis bah chantier un truc qui qui
collent pas et je kiffe faire des petits
films avec mes potes des films légaux
ya quinze ans je prends ma première
caméra et je fais mes petits sketches à
la manière des inconnus des nuls et puis
je sens que chante ya autre chose
ailleurs en fait et puis à la musique à
6 ans vous entré au conservatoire
musicales de reims nous apprenait le
violon alto pendant 12 ans et vous avez
l'oreille absolue c'est à dire que
pouvait reconnaître n'importe quelle
note comme ça à l'oreille oui je peux
essayer en tout cas est-ce qu'on peut
essayer
c'est un dos il ya eu 1 me ancien
arrière all away
alors
les rangs la question qu'on se pose
c'est une oreille absolue est ce que ça
se nettoie avec un coton-tige
donc après le bac vous intégrez la fac
de droit de reims
et les premiers jours un ami vous parle
du cours simon cours de théâtre à paris
vous y allez et c'est une révélation
j'apprends qu'on peut apprendre le
métier d'acteur en fait ouais c'est pas
que pour les maisons dans la télé ouais
c'est pas que pour les gens dans les
films et
et j'essaye en fait et je rentre dans ce
court et
j'assiste à un vrai changement s'il ya
des c'est rare dans la vie c'est pour ça
mais à une seule fois j'étais assis sur
un banc qui fait vraiment mal au cul
pour et tu dis ouah je veux tous les
matins de ma vie ce soit ça ouais et je
suis jamais revenue en fait voilà alors
à paris c'est pas facile pour autant
parce que pour payer les cours de
théâtre et la coloc parce que 12 mètres
carrés vous bossez à l'accueil dans une
banque d'affaires ouais je sais là
bonjour bien de travail
je me dis waouh si j'arrive à faire rire
des gens qui n'attendent rien de moi à
7h20 du matin je crois que je
et puis voilà après vous commencez à
faire des scènes et vous avez à new york
fait du stand up à new york c'est
incroyable c'est gonflé quand même bah
j'avais envié je me suis dit en fait il
y avait il y avait des scènes un peu
anglaise à paris et je commence à monter
à et le ballet mal à meskiana et two way
iranienne ton de biscayne c'est rare au
général des américains ils ont peur d
irène voilà j'y allais pas en jeu en
tant qu'iranien j'attends qu'on
française est encore plus marrant quand
tu dis bonjour je suis français est
marrant et ils sont morts de rire
après vous faites des télés quoi
commencer à bosser un petit peu la télé
fait clients cadres d'être
jusqu'au jour où vous inventez bref et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui si vous refusiez
bref ça serai bref j'ai reçu un chèque
de 3 millions de la csn
bref je baise avec qui je veux bref j'ai
dit non à la deuxième saison sur canal
c'est vrai
si j'avais voulu de l'argent j'aurais
fait une saison 2 voilà voilà vous
n'êtes plus malin que ça ouais ouais
l'article le long jeu artistique il
était plus important vous avez
s'attirant 80 deux épisodes on va pas
aller plus loin et voient pas surfer sur
un truc et peut-être qu'on fera un film
ouais on va essayer en tout cas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu